have the gum razzmatazz and welcome back
to surgeon simulator 2013 on the iPad
alright let's jump into this [ __ ]
right before my heart sometimes I I've
done this a million times Oh Bob it
looks like your face wants to go through
your body Bob if you try hard enough
your neck can go through your body try
it come on you look silly but let's try
it with me you look beautiful
Bob that's not what we're doing here
today we have to save your life all
right hammer time I guess then all right
hammer
they nerves the hammer the [ __ ] is this
[ __ ] what is that
all right Bob I don't know if you ever
been [ __ ] by a hammer but that just
happened there we go let's stab him with
a syringe all about her now what did he
die why how understand series arrow
instead well how do we brutal murder
I was saving hemp Bob don't you [ __ ]
die again
I'll kill you next time stupid Bob
doesn't even know how to live all right
mama imma imma have to tomahawk a [ __ ]
why does it not work stop [ __ ] all my
instruments this has nothing to do with
your survival but I just don't like you
I don't [ __ ] understand how do I turn
you off that click on you oh my god I'm
a genius you have to click the on button
I'm supposed to know that okay but
you're done y'see diet is that [ __ ]
dying on me again I swear to God why
does he have to have a heart rate now
what kind of fucked-up person are you
Bob yes you're free you're free go live
free in the wild oh [ __ ]
okay he's pleading we just Nick
I can't handle two retards at the same
time scalpel what that foot stop departs
my game dawg I think he's a Baba hater
all right
the heart is gone oh god damn it his
heart rate is dropping I don't
understand oh okay okay
just jam that [ __ ] in there oh my god
I'm Maria I'm practically a doctor
all right kidney transplant all right
pad I get it you don't like me I don't
like you but that doesn't mean we can't
have gays like there we go all right now
you [ __ ] wear this cuz I bought it to
you that's right now you don't have to
see how ugly you are I think I got his
penis I think I got it holy [ __ ] he's
talking like a horse it's attacking me
this is just like last night yes oh my
god go away go away goddamn it
okay Oh what the [ __ ] god damn it mom
what is trust me Bob you're way prettier
right now my mom would be scared if she
saw you Bob
this is way better this sister what the
[ __ ] really this is a buggy I love it oh
it's like where's my defibrillator later
turn this off no on on on on what do I
do
throw this oh there's to the flipper
clear clear it was beyond saving really
doesn't matter which doctor Bob was
doomed from the beginning
why don't you die I mean why can I say
there we go holy [ __ ] they all fly out
don't they I know the scarf are like
what happens here you have a little
friend it's name is Jared Jurgen I think
you guys can get along I ship them so
much hashtag dog man if I if my penis
could dance I would be so happy you have
a gift Bob you have a gift
son of a [ __ ] keep dying I don't
understand like I've never died Bob your
scarf wear it you're gonna get a cold
otherwise
that's right it's what the hell no I ran
out of batteries Hey
well [ __ ] there's a teeth transplant I
really should be the very first fashion
doctor look how much more kawaii you
became look at that do you have to die
all the [ __ ] time I swear to God like
get a [ __ ] life oh my god you're an
elephant
you're an ugly-ass elephant there we go
they're right there genius at work
thank you thank you thank you I tres
this is gonna be awesome so first of all
okay first of all I just want to ask you
Bob
why do you need a nice what never mind
actually hi Bob hi I'm right here I'm
right [ __ ] what is wrong with his eyes
okay he definitely needs an eye
transplant
seriously hide his [ __ ] eyes but what
is he doing what kind of drugs did you
take pop all right so first we need to
get this thing off his face I don't know
how to do that how do I get rid of the
glasses are we gonna have to break them
really
oh my god oh why did I say to [ __ ] their
guys is the hammer why did I say that's
right Bob
I said do it don't do it don't worry
this is standard procedure Oh God Oh get
it out get it out so much blood I can't
look me right there to step in no it's
stuck it's stuck
I don't know I can't oh god damn
I'm around what the [ __ ] I didn't sign
up for med school the [ __ ] aah
god damn it why can't we just remove
them I don't know but we're gonna have
to do it again okay the stand still and
maybe you won't [ __ ] happen again
what if this kind of glass why are you
dying oh god you're such a [ __ ] [ __ ]
seriously any anyone oh wow oh wow how
do we get rid of this [ __ ] the guys
sure maybe
yeah glass versus life that's a good
idea that did not work there we go
you're free Bob now I never transplanted
an eye before so you know pardon me if I
don't succeed oh [ __ ] okay well the
drill went to space that's fine I would
show you my tests because it'll be the
last thing you probably ever say but I
don't have tits I don't come on Bob you
need to stop doing that
you really really need to stop you're
freaking me out
where's the goddamn it that's disgusting
what the why is it so hard to get the
[ __ ] glasses up oh god stop but why
do you know this I I'm a pluck them out
I'm up top I'll fix this okay let me
just pull it out let me just pull it up
oh god that's nasty all right it's
almost on oh god do I have to do i what
qualified me to do this if I can't even
get the damn glasses off maybe I can cut
away the banner or something yeah I just
worry oh I wasn't supposed to hammer his
face well am I supposed to know
there we go that's that's a lot easier
hi pop don't worry about them that
little pools got traffic stop bleeding
thank you
Jesus Christ
we get the damn Izod I think it is this
machine Oh No all right I can't
I'm sorry Bob I can't it's too gross I
can't a new product from Apple I'll just
cut off but all right
well I guess you're just taking it one
and just plop it in there okay
I'm a [ __ ] miracle worker all right
sorry I'm gonna have to do that exact
same thing on your other eye
oh it's out its out its out okay okay
okay okay
which color do you want that color oh
you look fabulous
oh my god you look so good oh my god I
press I can act in this episode here and
the next one will do it teeth transpile
I'm sure let me just discuss at this one
they like enjoyed watching breaths hit
subscribe come birthday I'll see you in
the next one love your birthday awesome